hi I'm Erik Bosse and if Marvel face
board didn't totally win you over as a
veiled push to subscribe to Disney Plus
yeah as if we weren't already here just
take it Disney take it just $1 that no
there was more in there Marvel phase 5
is actually shaping up to be one of the
most interesting lineups of titles yet
with Deadpool recently hinted to make a
superhero landing in this era I'm gonna
break down all the missing titles
deliberately left out of phase four to
be revealed later in phase 5 when those
movies might come out and generally
everything we know about him is morally
warning for literally anything MCU
related at this point okay
recently Deadpool actor Ryan Reynolds
post on Instagram to mark the five-year
anniversary of the leaked referring to
the leaks Deadpool test footage in 2014
almost certainly by Reynolds himself
lynnie was hoping to urge the studio to
get moving on that Deadpool movie a
strategy that eventually worked but
looking closely this post there are
several clues hidden in it
so let's overanalyze the crap out of it
with another new rockstars tweet down
okay zooming and enhancing on this board
there are quite a few inside jokes nods
to Hugh Jackman Betty White
Reynolds why is bleak lively the
directors and writers of the first ed
Poole movie and randomly Daniel Ellsberg
that was a whistleblower connected to
the Pentagon Papers incident the 70s but
the big clue is the caption
investigation heading into year five or
as I call it phase five so this seems to
indicate that Reynolds either might know
something about plants for a Deadpool
movie in Marvel phase five or equally
likely this post is itself another
Reynolds release designed to create
Deadpool buzz and encouraged by geek to
include him in the face 5 lineup now if
I get and Disney have indicated they
absolutely intend to keep Deadpool alive
Feige has said that since Deadpool ain't
broke there's no need to fix it and
Disney head Bob Iger has indicated an
interest to continue making r-rated
Deadpool films and after Feige space for
announcement he did confirm that his
vague nod to mutants being in
development included both x-men and
Deadpool
I did mention mutants on the way I put
that boy in that category so let's
assume Deadpool in phase 5 is happening
what would this Deadpool inclusion tell
us about the rest of phase 5
well here's what else has been confirmed
phase 5 will probably launch in 2022 and
will include a blade film starring
Mahesh lolly and that could release as
early as February 2022 especially if
Marvel introduces blade in movies like
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness or in the Disney Plus Series Wan
division we also know that guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 is in the pipeline now
it sounds like the film was originally
going to be part of phase 4 maybe even
have LEM phase 4 in may 20 20 but the
James Gunn drama in summer 2018 did
cause delays leading gun to take on
Suicide Squad - for DC which will come
out in 2021 which mat guardians vol 3 -
after that perhaps putting it on track
for a May 20-22 release now it sounds
like guns original script was for the
story to be set before Thor love and
thunder but now it sounds like the
script will need to be revised for it to
be set after the events of Thor 11
Thunder which makes me think love and
thunder will be a pretty serious
game-changer for the whole cosmic MCU
and that the events of love and thunder
could result in some kind of crossover
between Thor Jane Foster Valkyrie Korg
and make other Asgardian figures with
the Guardian
Ravagers side of the universe in a way
it sounds like guardians volume three
story will focus on Rockets origin
perhaps a connection with a high
evolutionary as well as the search for
2014 Gamora after the events of endgame
and the interaction of Adam warlock
could be a good fit for Keanu Reeves
now also in the phase five pipeline will
likely be a third spider-man film home
Rex or whatever you want to call it
following Peter after getting outed and
framed in the final minutes apart from
home some have speculated that the
sinister six and/or Kraven the hunter
could play a role but perhaps this
Kraven having wakandan origins now since
far from home has now earned over a
billion dollars Sony and Marvel have got
to be back at work for a third film and
maybe we'll see it as soon as July 2022
and speed of Wakanda black panther 2 is
also definitely in the works with ryan
coogler confirmed to be working on the
script and rumors that Michael B Jordan
could return as kill monger in the
ancestral plane maybe you will see this
in November 2022 or maybe spring 2023
and similar deal and timeline for
Captain Marvel to that movie could pick
up from the other far from home post
credits scene for the scrolls Nick Fury
in space or finally a Secret Invasion
storyline I got a lot more scroll search
video to get back to now as we head into
2023 the future obviously gets a lot
hazy ER as if it wasn't already but
Kevin Feige has confirmed that Marvel
has both bases 4 & 5 planned out
covering the next five years we debated
what we should announce today should we
announce 4 & 5 we've planned them out
we've got 5 years down the road and in
that same interview fighting confirmed
details about a future Avengers movies
have you guys thought about like - you
know what the next Avengers team looks
like yes and it will be it will be a
very different team than we've seen
before that's what endgame was all about
yeah it would be a very different
incarnation of the team with some people
you've already met and some people you
haven't met ok so it sounds like
sometime in phase 5 we will see a new
Avengers film that could be May 20 23
and might include some lineup like
Falcon spider-man black panther Captain
Marvel Banner Hulk is still around but
also newcomers like blade Kate Bishop
Monica Rambeau spectrum with Tiana Paris
being introduced as the character in
Wanda vision now by the way there are
also some rumors that Black Widow might
be setting up a dark Avenger
movie with Elena Bulova and Red Guardian
leading an antihero team we'll see about
that
but that brings us back to Deadpool in
the mutants now there are a number of
ways mutants could be introduced in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe like one of
the snaps and infinity war and endgame
could have released a gamma radiation
shockwave that created mutations in some
people or some ripple in the multiverse
combined with Deadpool's time Medlin and
Deadpool - or we could see a House of M
storyline reversal with Scarlet Witch
having some kind of psionic meltdown and
creating a class of mutants I'm guessing
that Kevin fight you will want to reboot
the x-men lineup maybe Keanu is
Wolverine also not a bad option but
Reynolds post and everything we've heard
makes it sound like the Reynolds dead
pulled that we know in love will show up
in Marvel phase 5 you could join this
New Avengers film that we talked about
or you could just make wool cameos and
all of the phase 5 movies maybe picking
up the Cameo torch from the great Stan
Lee it would honestly be a kind of
perfect way for Deadpool to join this
universe but I think any x-men plans
will come after a Fantastic Four reboot
which Feige has confirmed is a major
priority in development there's been all
kinds of fan speculation for the casting
like maybe John Krasinski as Reed
Richards or Silver Surfer being a third
great option for Keanu can we account to
play everything please really I think
the Fantastic Four it presents Marvel
with its best option for a new major
villain with both Doctor Doom and
Galactus on the table they're actually
ant-man director Peyton Reed opened up
earlier this year that back in 2003 he
pitched a Fantastic Four movie that
would be set in the 60s inspired by the
Beatles film a hard day's night and
there have been some fan theories
stemming from that that the Fantastic
Four could have slipped into the quantum
realm in the 60s and then come back out
in the present day to find a world
filled with superheroes here for that so
I would say keep an eye out for Deadpool
cameos in 2022 and 2023 a Fantastic Four
movie in 2023 and an official x-men
reboot in 2024 all of which sounds way
too far from now but hopefully sooner
which title are you most looking forward
to
beyond phase four comment down below
with your thoughts follow me on
instagram twitter ID a boss and
subscribe to new rock stars or breakdown
some theories about everything Marvel
related thank you for joining me in this
discussion of phase five because as we
learn with phase four not all phases
will be aces
[Music]